[Aplausos]
[Música]
jamaica es un país famoso por bob marley
la música righi
quiero decir que jamaica es un país
famoso por muchas cosas mirar tienen la
música reggae la música ska los
rastafaris usain bolt que es el hombre
más rápido del mundo y todo esto en un
país de poco más de 3 millones de
habitantes
[Música]
dicho de otra manera que desde el punto
de vista de la cultura jamaica ha
aportado un montón de cosas al mundo
pero la política seguro que muchos
habéis ido de vacaciones algún que otro
resort en jamaica hay muchos y son
auténticos paraísos pero seguro que
nunca habréis oído escuchar de este país
en un periódico económico ni político y
no lo hacen porque en el mundo de las
finanzas internacionales jamaica es más
irrelevante que las fotos de comida que
te manda tu novia por whatsapp que no te
importan contestas con un emoticono de
carita sonriente por quedar bien pero ni
siquiera las has mirado pues en lo que
economía se refiere hammam acá anda
igual
[Música]
en lo que se refiere andan más o menos
al mismo nivel que armenia o filipinas
vamos que no están para tirar cohetes
pero esperad un momento porque las cosas
pueden empezar a cambiar atentos a la
noticia
[Música]
jamaica planea convertirse en un hub de
logística y transporte aéreo
los constructores proyectan un centro de
comercio global al nivel de singapur
dubai o rotterdam lo sé lo sé a mí
también me cuesta imaginarme lo estamos
hablando de pasar de esto
esto otro y suena un poco raro pero
tiene bastante sentido no me creéis pues
mirad este mapa aquí se ven las rutas
marítimas que pasan por el cariño
[Música]
[Aplausos]
como veis jamaica está situado cerca del
canal de panamá eso significa que hay un
montón de barcos que pasan por aquí y
que tienen que parar en algún punto para
llenar el depósito de combustible o
almacenar cargamentos si es verdad en la
mayor parte de los casos pueden usar los
almacenes y los puestos de combustible
del propio panamá pero cada vez son más
caros y todo esto explica por qué
kingston la capital de jamaica ya tiene
un montón de tráfico es una de las
mejores alternativas a panamá pero no
sólo eso desde hace un par de años se
terminaron las obras de expansión del
canal de panamá si antes tenía tráfico
ahora va a tener muchísimo más donde se
pueden construir puertos para que paren
los barcos antes de pasar por el canal
pues si os fijáis en el mapa veréis que
hay muy pocas alternativas
[Música]
estas islas que veis aquí en el mapa son
cuba y haití que son lugares alérgicos a
la inversión extranjera así que podemos
decir que jamaica es el único país que
puede recibir el dinero necesario para
construir infraestructura a esto le
tenemos que añadir otra super ventaja y
es que el idioma oficial de este país es
el inglés así que lo tienen todo
localización perfecta sueldos bajos y
todo ello en la lengua que habla el
mismísimo warren buffett pero la
pregunta es de verdad puede ocurrir esto
veremos algún día como los jamaicanos se
vuelven tan ricos como los singapurenses
o los holandeses hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia el paraíso perdido
el 6 de agosto de 1962 jamaica se
independizó del imperio británico y no
pasó absolutamente nada fue una
transición pacífica nada de guerras ni
de revoluciones los americanos les
dijeron a los british goodbye and thank
you y se montaron una república
parlamentaria al estilo de westminster
es como los americanos empezaron a
correr por su cuenta en principio con
muy buenas perspectivas los años 60
fueron buenos para el país que pasaba de
una economía agrícola a tener algo de
industria manufacturera algo de
inversión y todas esas cosas que hacen
que los países dejen de ser pop durante
los años 60 jamaica crecía a ritmos del
6% interanual es decir ritmos de país
emergente lo dicho todo muy bien hasta
los años 70 en esta época es cuando
surge la crisis del petróleo y jamaica
lo pasa especialmente mal la brecha
entre ricos y pobres aumentó y con ella
el resentimiento hacia la élite post
colonial y así es como michael manley
gana las elecciones
mandy era un socialista democrático al
que le caía muy bien la unión soviética
de repente jamaica empezó a tener
controles de precios expropiaciones
subidas del salario mínimo y una subida
enorme del gasto público la idea inicial
era crear una red de protección para los
americanos más pobres entre otras muchas
cosas buenas
manley uso educación
y bajas de maternidad y muchísimos
programas sociales pero lo cierto es que
sin movimiento económico todos estos
programas se quedaron en buenas
intenciones y vamos a ver las
restricciones y los controles de precios
son mala idea si quieres que tu economía
no entra en crisis a esto hay que
añadirle que el señor mandli era amigo
de fidel castro y que sus relaciones con
los v6
estaban en es complicado conclusión la
inversión extranjera desapareció y la
clase media se marchó del país
de repente jamaica se vio con una
inflación de dos dígitos que unida a los
controles de precios llegó al país a
sufrir escasez de alimentos básicos
en otras palabras jamaica se convirtió
en algo estilo en venezuela pero versión
baja en calorías todo esto explica que
en los años 80 los jamaicanos le irían a
la patada a michael manley y pusieron un
presidente de derechas de repente el
señor edward seaga volvió a tener buenas
relaciones con reino unido y estados
unidos y jamaica pasó de alabar a fidel
castro- a ayudar al ejército gringo con
la invasión de granadas
y de golpe y porrazo y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando los de visual política
vuelven a las andadas en 2020 ahora nos
van a contar cómo hay casas rica gracias
a echarse en los brazos de los gringos y
al neoliberalismo esto es de visual
polític siempre están del lado de los
yankees pues no listo la historia no va
por ahí ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
la encrucijada del caos los americanos
son famosos por tomarse la vida con
calma de hecho incluso en su dialecto
del inglés tienen su propia expresión
para decir algo así como que no hay
problema la expresión por cierto es
jamón no sé exactamente cómo se
pronuncia pero hay que dar pero la
realidad es que digan lo que digan los
jamaicanos tienen un problema y es un
problema bastante grande
se extiende el estado de emergencia a
los viajeros que van a jamaica debido a
los altos niveles de criminalidad ya lo
habéis visto desde fuera jamaica parece
el gran lebowski a tamaño real pero
vista desde dentro jamaica es más bien
fargo un país ultra violento pero
violento de verdad la tasa de homicidios
de jamaica es ocho veces la media global
en el año 2005 jamaica tenía una tasa de
58 homicidios por cada 100.000 personas
que fue la más alta ese año y en 2017
esta tasa bajó a 57 homicidios por
100.000 habitantes sólo superada por el
salvador y diréis de dónde viene toda
esta violencia pues básicamente de los
años 70 veréis en lugar de contratar a
asesores de comunicación política los
principales partidos políticos se
dedicaron a armar a bandas callejeras
así tal cual después cuando eeuu quiso
intervenir en la política americana
también se dedicó a dar armas a las
bandas del partido laborista que por
cierto en este país es el partido de
derechas y que creéis que hizo la unión
soviética pues darle armas a las bandas
del partido nacional que es el partido
de izquierdas
para que os hagáis una idea en 1980 casi
800 personas habían sido asesinadas por
violencia política
de hecho en kingston todavía hay zonas
que están segregadas por ideología dicho
de otra forma que si un día os echáis un
novio o novia de jamaica y os lleva a
ver a la familia mejor no habléis de
política y os lo digo en serio porque
todavía hoy en día los partidos siguen
dando armas a las bandas callejeras creo
que eso es lo que entienden en estas
zonas por marketing de guerrilla y por
supuesto allí donde hay violencia
política también hay narco violencia
porque como os podéis imaginar jamaica
también está en medio de las redes de
narcotráfico vamos que lo tienen todo
y lo cierto es que lo que a recursos
naturales respecta jamaica tampoco tiene
grandes cosas que ofrecer a el mundo
vale si tienen azúcar café bauxita en
fin nada especial y el turismo es cierto
que podría dar muchísimo dinero tampoco
es un sector estable a fin de cuentas
con tantísimos crímenes hay que ser muy
fan de bob marley para querer seguir a
jamaica en otras palabras que jamaica
exporta poco pero sin embargo importa
muchísimo porque siendo una isla en
mitad del caribe necesitan importarlo
todo comida medicinas y hasta energía y
todo esto explica que el país tenga un
déficit comercial de 4 mil 500 millones
de dólares se juntamos todas estas
desgracias económicas y sociales y las
ponemos en un cóctel que tenemos pues
tenemos estanflación y que es la
estanflación pues atentos porque esa es
una de esas bonitas palabras que sólo se
aprenden si veis visual político pero
que os harán parecer muy inteligentes en
las cenas familiares y comidas de
empresa a no ser que viváis en janeiro
[Música]
estanflación es una combinación de
estancamiento económico desempleo e
inflación
vamos la repera por cierto que después
de habernos enseñado semejante elección
económica es hora de recordaros que
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribiros a visual política y
darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones pero
volvamos con la historia
decíamos que jamaica lleva 50 años
arrastrando desempleo inflación y
estancamiento económico eso cómo se
llamaba exacto estanflación los
jamaicanos llevan básicamente toda su
vida en crisis sin embargo las cosas
pueden cambiar de repente ha surgido una
oportunidad para que jamaica pueda dar
un giro de 180 grados a su historia
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
y estar en el sitio indicado el 26 de
junio de 2016 ocurrió algo nunca visto
antes en el mundo entero un enorme barco
mercante cruzaba el canal de panamá este
barco era tan grande que hasta la fecha
habría sido imposible que pudiera cruzar
un canal si amigos de visual político
ese fue el día en el que el canal de
panamá terminó sus obras de expansión
hablamos de una expansión que ha doblado
la capacidad del canal y que ha servido
para crear un nuevo tipo de barco el
nuevo panamax que es un tipo de
embarcación mucho más grande de lo que
estábamos acostumbrados vamos que es el
nacho vidal de los mares pues bien sólo
en los próximos 20 meses habrá como 3000
barcos de este tipo cruzando el canal y
esto explica noticias como esta
y el caribe supone una porción cada vez
más grande en la logística global y os
preguntaréis a dónde van todos estos
barcos pues a todas partes del mundo
mercancías que viajan de china a florida
o de españa a ecuador pasan en algún
momento por jamaica y diréis pero por
qué pasan por jamaica pues porque
necesitan repostar a por combustible o
necesitan almacenar mercancías por algún
momento o simplemente necesitan
reparaciones panamá ya está llena de
barcos así que tener una isla cerca que
además es más barata les viene de perlas
y por eso jamaica quiere aprovechar su
situación
el problema pues que para eso necesita
montones de puertos aeropuertos
carreteras y puertos secos para reparar
los barcos la ventaja pues que el resto
de países del caribe no son una
competencia seria
haití y cuba serían las principales
alternativas pero el primero es un
auténtico avispero y el segundo es un
país comunista donde no les gusta la
inversión extranjera también tenemos a
puerto rico que está en crisis y
república dominicana- que en realidad es
el único país que podría competir
seriamente con jamaica sin embargo aquí
creo que hay suficiente mercado para los
dos así que si los jamaicanos hacen bien
las cosas pueden dar un pelotazo único
en su historia como decíamos antes
jamaica es una democracia con sus
problemas pero una democracia es miembro
de la commonwealth y habla inglés de
hecho tanto el gobierno como algunos
inversores ya han buscado lugares donde
construir toda la infraestructura que
van a necesitar
[Aplausos]
qué es lo que necesitan ahora pues que
alguien de verdad ponga el dinero encima
de la mesa y aquí es donde llega el
mayor obstáculo hablamos de unos 28 mil
millones de dólares eso es el coste de
dos juegos olímpicos como los de londres
y si es verdad invertir en jamaica
significaría reducir costes de
transporte para todos es decir productos
más baratos para todo el mundo pero
estaréis de acuerdo conmigo en que es
difícil convencer a los inversores de
que metan su dinero en un sitio donde
prácticamente es más fácil morir
asesinado que pillar un catarro así que
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
realmente creéis que jamaica puede salir
de la pobreza con este proyecto invertir
y aysén un país así o tal vez jamaica va
a seguir en esa espiral de violencia por
más tiempo podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre recordad que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribimos a visual político y darle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo darle al like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
ah
[Música]